okay I guess
expensive
okay I guess when I call a meeting to
order
get a hold of that we're here today for
um Senate Bill 269 well the establishing
a commission to study energy saving
weatherization programs we are here to
either recommend for future legislation
or and not for future legislation
foreign
just to remind everyone using
microphones because we are on so
probably when you make a guess which is
um
you know the Electric and Gas Utilities
get to put things on the rates and put
some charges on the rate to pay for the
weatherization whereas
um you know how do you get an oil
company to
chip in how do you calculate how much
they're going to do and it's it seems
like a
kind of a difficult not a difficult
question to answer and and I'm not sure
how necessary it is we do have to fund
Energy Efficiency if we're going to do
it but um
I think that's kind of the question that
was being asked in that part of the bill
that's just my guess
it's what makes sense to me
yes I would agree with that
um I I think the bottom line is we're
asked we're going to be asking with this
it would be to take a look at asking the
gas and oil companies to uh
put funding towards weatherization which
just means that they're going to
increase the costs it's going to be
passed on
to the consumer and at this point in
time I think it's not a great idea
because of what the crisis that we're
having with the high cost of energy at
the moment
how are how are we proceeding here are
we going
um
are we picking are we going down through
the through the bill
sent line by line it doesn't seem to uh
I don't I would say that the way we
should um
the way I would like to go through it is
too
gosh first of all I have I have a
revised
version for the bill which starts with
definitions
like first one is building Energy
Efficiency what's the Energy Efficiency
of a building what is it that we're
talking about
a second one is weatherized what does
that mean
third one energy audit what does that
mean
Energy Efficiency program what does that
mean and then we go with a declaration
of purpose which is basically where the
original Bill started
but I think we have to know what we're
talking about before we uh
think about how to improve this bill
and uh if I if I could be allowed to I
after um after representative Kelly
Pitts has
and this discussion as part of the
discussion has finished I'd be perfectly
happy to
go over my definitions
I guess I have nothing to lose now
nothing to gain I believe that this bill
as written
should not go forward
I believe that we do not need another
study committee
I believe that weatherization I think
everybody in this room I'm just gonna
I'll speak for myself and I'm almost
everybody thinks that weatherization is
important and that is a big bang for the
buck
and that's where I think it needs to
stop this bill cannot be amended this
bill cannot be approved in this session
what has to happen is that we have a
clean bill
and have it brought back next year
next session and I can't do it for
consideration and I think that the
weatherization program I think it needs
to be ramped up
and we're talking now I believe about
home weatherization uh we start to get
into the Weeds about should we charge a
surcharge on oil per gallon should we
charge a per cubic foot on gas I think
that's going to just make this whole
thing a mess
so I don't know if you ready to
entertain a motion yet but if I was
going to make a motion it would be that
this bill as written should stay here
and a completely new clean bill
be written perhaps to up the ante a
little bit for weatherization because we
know that's the biggest bang for the
buck right now
thank you uh I agree with representative
Kelly Pitts there
are a lot of things happening right now
that
make
that'll be a five dollar fine for you
that make um
moving forward with a commission and
remember that's the subject of this bill
is the creation of a commission
so
if we were to recommend this bill for
future legislation it would be to create
a commission
with everything that's happening
with the inflation reduction act and all
the money that it provides for
Energy Efficiency and home
weatherization
the landscape is changing dramatically
des and the department of energy are
going to be authorized to spend millions
of dollars on Energy Efficiency
in the next year to
three four years
so I'm not sure that there's any value
in creating a commission to study
this question
now that we have a department of energy
they have folks in the department whose
job it is to pay attention to Energy
Efficiency and whether at home
weatherization they're going to be
doling out the federal dollars to make
that happen
so as representative Kelly Pitts said
this bill
which just creates a commission to
further study this question
probably isn't going to provide any
useful information
and so I would recommend that we not
recommend that this bill this bill for
future legislation
and as representative Kelly Pitts has
suggested that
somebody bring forth a clean bill
uh
after the November elections to
make some further a Headway on Energy
Efficiency and home weatherization in
consultation with the Department of
energy to try to get
an understanding of how the landscape is
going to change with the infusion of all
these federal dollars
that would be my take for the moment
got it
so okay
um that's the procedural question we
have six members here today and I would
hate to see this bill deadlocked because
of that
on five
John
four five
oh okay okay
I stand corrected thank you
okay but I've seen six people here
I know I'm not a voting member I'm just
an interested Observer I am seeing six
people here though
and okay I am right about that okay yeah
um
there are seven people but yeah yeah uh
sure um six voting members with a
potential for gridlock okay
doing is recommendous
communicating on Thursday okay thank you
for explaining that
okay
I did not understand that Thai Vault
would result in a
non-recommendation okay so thank you
oh thank you I um
I think the bill with some is a very
important bill because of the
the concept of the study the fact that
we're going to have
a concrete piece of
understanding about what we mean by
Energy Efficiency what we mean by what
we uh what we think we ought to be doing
and so on
and um I would like to explain a few
things so that I can because I will use
a vocabulary
that I I want everybody to understand
and if I could just run through a few of
the things that um that I have come up
with
uh you might change your mind about this
bill in terms of whether it's worth
going forward with
so if you don't mind I'll take about
five minutes or 10 minutes
we're discussing here about establishing
a commission we're not talking about the
the nuances here so that's we're either
going to be yay on a commission so this
is
not pertaining to the bill what you want
to do
okay then I then I I wonder then I will
have if I have to speak to that um
see
when you read the original bill
obviously their interest the interest is
in Energy Efficiency for people's houses
when you talk about a grandmother
or
with little kids in the house and the
house is difficult to eat you're not
talking about you know Theory or
politics or anything you're talking
about
doing something that needs to be done in
this state
so let me just run through some
definitions really quickly and I think
if you hear them you might understand
what I'm getting at
and I should have the I believe I should
be able to I should have the right to um
make myself clear
first of all we're talking about the
Energy Efficiency of buildings
it's called building Energy Efficiency
it's about how well the building
maintains a suitable environment for the
building's purposes
despite whatever weather is going on
outside whether it's freezing winter or
hot summer
weatherize means which we see it all the
time
means improving the house finding out
whether or not is doing an adequate job
in terms of Energy Efficiency
and then implementing uh measures of
various sorts
from adding insulation to
um
perhaps changing some windows
that would make the building operate
more efficiently as a building in other
words and the result of that would be a
major drop in
or significant drop in the cost not just
for electricity but also for any of the
fuel it's used for example a house
heated by oil has an oil furnace burning
oil and it has several electric pumps
that run that oil furnace and distribute
the warm air or the hot water around the
house
weatherization starts
with a
it's a two-step process weatherization
starts with what's called an audit where
someone who is professionally
competent goes into the building and
figures out where the building is
lacking
in Energy Efficiency one of the tools
for example is to depressurize the
building with a fan and then go around
with a infrared scanner and find out
where all the cold air is coming in
really very effective tool
um that's what an energy audit typically
is I did see one energy on it where the
houses in a development were very well
understood
and all the person had to do was to find
out whether there was insulation in the
walls or not the rest of it was obvious
so I think
um and finally an Energy Efficiency
program
is something done by a community or a
state
to get all the buildings
in the community of State
over time gradually
weatherized so that they perform much
better in terms of Energy Efficiency
this saves uh this has tremendous
benefits not just for the family in the
building but also for the state economy
we have some very unusual
things going on in our state today
we joined the regional greenhouse gas
initiative and instead of using the
money for
reducing CO2 emissions
we give it back to rate payers they get
about 65 cents to a dollar a month
rebate on electric bills for example
according to two of the representatives
for a couple of years ago
so so I'm a family I'm getting a dollar
a month
rebate
from Reggie so it you know I get a
dollar a month that's nice
but I pay the oil companies
eight dollars a month more because the
house is not insulated and I pay the
electric bill two dollars or three
dollars more because the house is not
insulated
this is this is you know this is
ridiculous this is awful
so what we need and what this original
bill was calling for is to somebody to
lay down the facts about what Energy
Efficiency is about and why it's
important
and this idea of forgetting about the
bill
and footing around and then
talking about the department of energy
about which we know nothing
nothing
is just a rotten way to treat the
citizens of this state
the three states around us there are
three Northern
New England State's Maine New Hampshire
and Vermont all have excellent
Energy Efficiency programs
one of the energy conferences I went
about two or three years ago they were
laughing at New Hampshire
they had reports from those three states
about how their programs were going
and the title of the conference of that
particular
um
part of the conference was
reports from the donut
the joke being of course that New
Hampshire is the whole
it really is appalling and I think as
politicians that would like to get
reelected I think it would be really
sensible for us to stand up and bang our
fists on the table and say God damn it
we're going to do Energy Efficiency I'm
sorry
now I want to give you a couple of more
things my daughter bought a house
we're doing the merits of the bill your
time enough you you want to do your
definitions we gave you a lot of
latitude but we're done now no we're
done we're done we're moving on we have
a motion on the floor
and I didn't have a second on it but we
have a motion on the floor not to go
forward on this
the idea of a commission is to have
a very important topic discussed in a
formal manner
that's what it's about is to have a
formal
recognized
discussion
about an important issue
and the commission should go forward and
create a block a concrete block that
says this is what we're going to do
that's what this is about or
this is what we're not going to do
whatever it is it's a very important
topic
Jose you haven't had a speak you have
any chance
I would like to second the motion to not
put forth a to make a recommendation to
not put forth this bill
motion is second on the floor
I understand John's passion because John
has been passionate all the years he has
been on this committee about
weatherization
and I think he has convinced most of us
that it's an important program
the understanding that I think is not
there is that this bill can't go forward
way it is no matter what we say we
recommend that it go forward all it is
saying is somebody
is going to pick it up and I'm looking
at probably Lewis
to put forward a
Bill Lucius a bill
that will that will move forward and
move through the legislature next year
this legislature has taken many steps
and one of them was raising the income
limit on the on the fuel assistance well
maybe that's something that needs to be
done on weatherization because people
who are living
like myself
a flush away
probably could use it I live in an
apartment and I can't but perhaps that's
one of the steps we could take
the makeup of the commission
as I'm looking at it here is everybody
who has a special interest
so I think you need to really look at
these things and that will be looked at
next session
and hopefully something meaningful will
pass in the first year
we all realize that we need help and we
need things done now
and we're getting them done now and I
commend John for his passion
sometimes passions get out of hand and I
know that as well as anybody
but
this can't get done now even if we say
go ahead we recommend that it move
forward that does not bind the next
committee and there's nothing we can do
with this one in front of us it is
sufficient it is dead for all practical
purposes and the way we always refer to
a bill that was studied in the second
session is
a nice death
so we we all understand John and I think
all the members of this committee who
are coming back understand and I see our
department of energy out there and I
think they understand what the feeling
of this committee is but this bill for
all practical purposes the way it's
written now is dead
I'd like to point out a couple of things
number one this bill
delegates three duties to the commission
two of those duties
probably aren't going to be able to be
ha make happen
number one it says policy direction to
further further prioritize
weatherization within the existing New
Hampshire saves programs
in HB 549
the determination
that
the system benefits charge can only be
used 65 percent of it can be used only
for
electrical energy efficiency is going to
shrink the weatherization programs
within New Hampshire saves
so that policy duty of this commission
probably is going to go nowhere
number three is use of other funding
sources such as Grant funds and that's
going to be the purview of the
Department of energy to uh
find ways to allocate the resources that
are coming down from the federal
government and other places
so if two out of the three duties of
this Commission
are virtually impossible to to carry out
then it seems to me that
there's no point in going forward with
this Commission
yes thank you sure
um
I tend to agree with my esteemed
colleague of
representative Vose on this one I really
think that I would like to see whether
they should go forward because we if we
do as uh as a representative man has
pointed out if we reduce our demand for
electricity
academics dictate the cost will go down
greatly for for our ratepayers I think
we have to do something but I really
feel that
this commission is written here is not
going to address all the issues that we
really need to address
and I'd have
actually a little more to say than
beyond that so thank you
the notion what we're doing here is
making a recommendation to our full
committee what is the full committee
going to do with this bill
and
I understand the points had been raised
don't don't agree with all of them
but I think it's important for this
working group
to say in its recommendation to the full
committee
weatherization is an essential part of
the program that we need to take
responsibility for and because we have
the federal funding because it's
possible because we have these people
hired at doe whose responsibility it is
now is our opportunity so let's make it
happen now I think the way to accomplish
that is to pass this and to say to the
to our full committee we recommend this
because we want this issue dealt with we
want people in the state helped
now you can read it the other way and
say we don't need a commission to do
that therefore let's not recommend it
you know as long as we get the message
to the committee that this is essential
and we want someone on the committee to
pick it up and run with it with an LSR
that goes in December and something
happens in January and people can be
helped
that's that's what we want to do and I
think we're all in favor of that
yeah um
it's almost as if we're deciding
uh here
that uh
uh you know we're sort of replacing what
would should be the conclusion of a very
well designed and uh
Commission of people that know what
they're talking about and can discuss
and argue
with lots of intelligence
and we're replacing that with just
hey we don't think the bill is ready
of course it's not ready
of course it'd have to be amended
significantly significantly
but it's if you just look at the
topics to be discussed in this
Commission
it just about covers the ground and it
needs to be done we have we are so
backward in this state
let me give you a couple of just a
couple of more examples
my wife bought a house in Massachusetts
it was covered with asbestos shingles
look like Manchester
buildings nasty old building
she paid a lot of money for it she had
an energy efficiency
audit done they came in and for nine
hundred dollars more they insulated the
entire house
from inside because you couldn't go
through asbestos shingles
she paid ninety four thousand dollars
for the house for a few years later
before we moved here to New Hampshire
which is where she grew up
she sold it for three hundred and fifty
thousand dollars Zillow has it for about
1.7 million now
Energy Efficiency is important to the
value of a house
it gives you it gives the owners money
gives the owners a return on investment
I would like to also say
that automation is getting rid of a lot
of working class jobs
and we know that
and doing the Energy Efficiency work
blowing insulation into walls is not
difficult work
but it takes Manpower
and it offers jobs and the jobs are not
only
reasonable to do and pay reasonably well
but they are worthwhile and the people
doing it you can see they really feel
they are doing something
for the homeowner
this would be very valuable for all
those people that look would are looking
for work
there's a huge benefit to this and it
isn't just people saving a little money
on their electric bill or their oil bill
my library had a competent audit done
and we saved
58 off the original heating bill
it's a stone building
it was impossible to insulate any of the
walls
I had a lot of experience with Energy
Efficiency I have no personal interest
in this I want to know that
my house is a perfect
perfectly constructed
perfectly designed Energy Efficiency
house
we have to have air circulated by
electricity
to make sure we have breathable air in
the house during the winter
we don't burn anything for fuel for the
first few years we had a wood stove
now we have a heat pump
Energy Efficiency can do a hell of a lot
for us and for future Generations who
have to live in the climate that we
leave for them and we can do our share
I I just want I you know I know this is
I I don't know about being tape but I
don't want anybody to get the idea that
this committee's been sitting on its
hands
long before you John we passed the
Community College course and auditing so
an efficiency auditing so that people
could come in and be proficient at what
they're doing
um this committee has worked and I'm
going to speak for myself now because
this is probably well my next meeting
will be the last we have worked
diligently to try and get the best we
can
for energy usage to push that down
to make things better to take care of
wood stoves that were polluting the cane
area because of the bowl
we have done all that
and there's still a lot more to be done
and it will be done
and I will ask you
sit down with
the committee
at some point before filing period is
over and draft a new bill to accomplish
what we need to accomplish and that bill
should be fast tracked it shouldn't be a
bill that is going to sit around for
next year and then get studied it should
be a fast track Bill and you also sit
down with the governor's people to make
sure that it can get done you can do
that anybody on this committee can do it
and together
we'll accomplish it because I think the
goal of everybody and I'm going to speak
for the Senate too far be it from me
I'll speak for Jeb Bradley
all of us
well he was my first chairman so I can
speak from all of us want to accomplish
that and all of us have been working for
years
to accomplish the same thing but there's
only one way to do it and that's
together
this bill is not the vehicle but there
is a bill out there I'm sure of it
that will come out of your mind will
come out of least we'll we're gone but
we're not dead
so that's my parting Salvo and I will
ask the chair to call a question
we'll do a roll call on the uh
on YouTube
we have a motion a second we've already
discussed it you've we've gave you your
time and you spoke well and passionately
but we're going to call the roll
ing
okay
issue
so we are not recommending it through
the legislation yay
yes
no
Mr chair for me
I want to
and I I'm sure
representative Rosewood
uh we're coming back for meeting next
Thursday but representative Mann is not
going to be here oh you are I was going
to thank you so I'm not going to thank
you now all right forget it
[Laughter]
so I would like to thank all the members
of this of the subcommittee for this
discussion here this afternoon
uh John it's always good to hear from
you I'm glad you were able to be here
today and we can discuss it again some
more on Thursday if need be but I think
this was a good discussion and I thank
you all for being here